At the foot of Lothric Castle, an old path still runs below the tower in the Undead Settlement.
It was used to transport sacrifices to the Cathedral of the Deep.
You should see where it leads....
if you've the stones for it
*Breathy Cackle*
So, we're travelling along the Road of Sacrifices toward the Cathedral of the Deep
and Aldrich, Saint of the Deep, apparently lies within.
Aldrich is a Lord of Cinder
And a Lord of Cinder is someone who has linked the fire
in a previous age.
The were so mighty and powerful that they could link
the fire and extend the age of flame.
But that was in a past age and now alongside
the other Lords of Cinder, Aldrich has been resurrected
to link the fire once more, but this time
he's hiding from his duty, he's run away
to his home, at the base of Lothric Castle.
The Crestfallen Knight speaks of sacrifices
that were presumably going to Aldrich
because Aldrich is referenced as a devourer of men.
So this path to Aldrich, this Road of Sacrifices,
I think it was used a long time ago.
Because this path is now crawling with Corvian
creatures, who were these deformed beast-men
who we learn more about from their weapons.
And they have a fascinating little story.
The Storyteller's Staff reveals that the casters are
heretical storytellers who share tales of the
Painted World to forlorn souls, however the
tellers themselves, they're also wretched beings
with no place to go.
The Corvians with the great knife are named as
unwanted. They're guided by the storytellers and
they wield this big old knife that is used to intimidate
foes, but all it does reveal how afraid they are
themselves. Because they fight like animals backed
into a corner.
Some wield great Corvian Scythes, which directly
reference Priscilla of the Painted World.
And there are so many similarities between these
creatures and Priscilla. Uhh, if you remember Priscilla
was a crossbreed between a dragon and most likely
a Lord, or a God. She was locked away in a painting
Where she speaks affectionately of all the other
unwanted beings that were locked away with her.
"Priscilla speaks" This land is peaceful.. its inhabitants kind.
"Vaati begins narration again" So by mimicking Priscilla's
weaponry, and by telling us stories it's really clear
that these creatures admire, or maybe even worship her.
Because these are unwanted, lost creatures, and Priscilla
is the champion of the deformed, and the unwanted, and the rejected.
If you drop off the bridge here you'll find this hidden
little alcove, this cavethat  hides Morne's ring and a Divine
Braille tome. And in Episode 3 we actually rescued the
two characters that these items are associated with.
Uhhh, Eygon of Carim, and his captive Irina.
So considering how close this little cave is and the items
within it I really imagine these two sitting here, resting
on their journey to their next destination. Eygon is
a knight of Carim and Morne's Ring is a ring that's
given to knights of Carim to boost miracles.
The character named Morne we haven't met yet, and we
might never meet him. He's described to be this
high-ranking apostle within Carim's church system
and he laboured with the Goddess Caitha to provide
comfort to the suffering. Caitha has been referenced
before. She's really frequently mentioned in Dark Souls
II descriptions as this goddess of tears, who's
known as a compassionate being that's with us
in times of tragedy. Although, there's some item
descriptions that say that she's a demoness, that guides
us toward misfortune.
And finally, we clear the Road of Sacrifices and
below us is the Crucifixion Woods, but before that
we come across a unkindled traveller who is coming
through here in a much the same way we are.
, and that's something I missed in Bloodborne.
Dark Souls is very much about meeting characters
who really inhabit the same world you do and
empathize with the same struggles.
Anri's Narration Continues
Beyond the flooded woods lies Farron Keep
home of the Undead Legion. Further yet is the Cathedral of the Deep.
Vaati Continues
So Anri of Astora is female here, right? But if you play as
a female character then she'll be a man.
You'll understand why this is in a later episode, I
promise. And I can't wait until April 12th, when everyone
has this game, and when I can invade you guys.
As of this date only press and streamers have access to
the english PC version, and, while the current early
access system is this complete mess, it's completely
screwed up that the game is out early like this.
I just can't help but cover it early, I'm sorry.
Making videos is half the fun for me, I can't resist.
One good thing did come out of it, though. I was the first
to kill PvP streamer Peeve Peeverson, so that was fun
I mean it was fun for me, I don't know if it was fun for
him. But, uh, he gets me back for it later, so it's okay.
Back at the shrine we meet Sirris, of the Sunless Realms.
She certainly fits the bill as a blade of the Dark Moon
and the Sunless Realms could well be a reference to
Anor Londo and the illusion of sunlight that Gwyndolin
projected upon it, all that time ago. But that remains to be seen
and remains to be confirmed. Back in the woods
we take out the giant enemy crab, that you'll have to
take out fairly quickly, otherwise it can actually bury
back beneath the ground and come up again with
full health. One of them drops the Great Swamp Ring
which boosts pyromancy and reminds us that pyromancy
is supposedly born of the Chaos Flame.
Nearby is the conjurer set and a tome that teaches us
ancient pyromancies. So let's have a talk about
pyromancy. If you're rusty on your Dark Souls lore
remember that the Chaos Flame was created long ago
by the witch of Izaloth. The Witch tried to create a flame
that could replace the fading first flame, so that the light
of the world could be restored, but everything went
wrong. And, instead, the flame consumed her and
spiraled out of control and created demons. One of the
witch's sisters escaped and became the mother of
pyromancy. Her name was Quelana, and her art was
borne of the Chaos Flame. She taught apprentices
, the art was passed down, and as a result the further
back you go with pyromancy, the closer you get to the
more powerful, the more primal spells. Cornyx, a
pyromancer we met in the Undead Settlement tells us
of this.
Cornyx's Narration Continues
At least, that is what pyromancers of the Great Swamp
believe.
The place is called Izalith.
Vaati Continues
He says that the lands of the Lords converge upon
Lothric, and that Izalith drifts comparatively close as
well. So just like characters and souls are reborn and
we see them again, just as time is convoluted, and people
are shifting in and out. Are powerful places somehow drawn
closer to the land of the Lords when the flame fades
as well? Could this explain what Emma said about the
Lords of Cinder?
Within the central ruins of The Crucifixion Woods is a
familiar figure.
This Crystal Sage is one of two sages that went on to
ally with the Undead Legion.
He did so to train the Sorcerers of Farron, which
explains the multitude of undead sorcerers we
we just fought our way through.
These Sorcerers of Farron's Abyss Watchers were
known to be lonesome warriors who would only
rely upon more pragmatic spells.
Phase two of the Sage is ridiculous. That was probably
the boss that I had the most trouble with on my first
play through. I must have attempted it like five times,
because all of these illusions shoot so many spells.
And it's difficult to dodge them and not get stun-locked
So my advice for this 1. Do a lot of strafing and sprinting.
And if you have a heavy weapon, just switch it out to a
fist and smack one of the illusions and move on to the
next one. And the when you get to the real boss,
just smack him into the ground.
A sorcerer with his sanity does remain within the Ruined
Keep.
Around him are hundreds of valuable scrolls.
The hard work of an entire lifetime.
Sorry! I had to do that.
As we return to the Firelink Shrine, Yuria tells us about
her growing concern with Orbeck.
Let me know if you liked this episode. This one was
much more focused on the lore, but I could also focus
more on tips, or items, or little tricks that I've learned on
my first play through. So, let me know, and I'll see you
next time.
Closed Captions by: RainbowGoober